welcome welcome welcome what the [ __ ] is
huh I'm actually terrified I think I'm
moving I'm not sure all right let's see
what happens in here all right well this
doesn't look too bad I'm so fast
Wow let's go baby all the nostalgia
mixed with what the [ __ ] Ness this is
astounding
Jesus how now it seems pretty normal
nevermind nevermind alright let's go
through the cannon then I guess no
nevermind
oh now I'm skiing that's great I was
hoping for that whoo
skiing every day brother no net ski Oh
God drugs okay okay I want it whoo I'm
pretty sure this is how Moria is on
drugs like I don't forget no one can
question it oh of course
yes of course I'm a giant I knew that
all along
oh of course yeah so mom please
oh god here comes to nightmares I got
big my assets
it's [ __ ] glorious oh yeah Mario uh
yeah
oh no no rainbow Mario what are you
doing man
this is the trickiest experience on my
life like this is just ridiculous
where'd I go why did that go I got a
star I got a star I got a star how did I
get a star fix that haircut my sign I'm
a [ __ ] sign what is good I want to go
in the cannon as a sign can I can I
please I saw a sign that nevermind I
guess and it open uh I don't like being
a sign this world is rejecting the signs
I will complete this game as a sign
you haven't lived until you play
supermario sign sign edition there we go
oh look it make get awake by a sign
brother alright we're doing well
I like this sign thing I don't know
what's up with the same thing but I like
it it's actually pretty like fun
refreshing way to play super mario 64 I
actually like it man I remember these
jumps when you were a ah no no no it's
not fair
please no no no no no what extra life
extra life okay okay what happened
stop oh okay all right well you know
what
[ __ ] happens everything is following me
now I have a quite beyond a rush I like
it you everyone
everyone wants to be a bro these days
huh you okay then that's great did did
it did it and they crashed hey sign how
you doing are you free on Saturday be
area tech you did what now now I'm not a
sign anymore now I'm a tiny sign now I'm
a sad sign no yeah hahaha
alright we're here okay okay I'm so
scared the controls are just is this
worth it oh god oh god now uh-huh
alright we made it to the top boss
battle time baby fight me in real life
I'm a sign [ __ ] I don't care about as
your hipster mustaches I am a shine
don't know how to kill this buzz but I
oh god no let me go oh you can't just
throw me the brother dammit the game
freezes every time I take him [ __ ] this
No Oh
the feels well at least I'm a sign no no
no it's not fair man I'll thank God it's
a ah son no please dad stop making me
sliding oh god it's so creak I got a
star of course of course I got a start
I earned that shed now wait what what
happened exciting Mario you're great at
moonwalking but this needs to stop
where are you going yeah you go Mario
you go and you go fast damn it don't
throw me please thank you
ok sure
let's go together I guess ok sure why
not
uh we're coming back that's great I was
that's love I guess that's love for you
I can show you a world where Mario has a
nun to rush are you it's dangerous ahead
so listen up
take my advice thank you whatever advice
he has I want oh hell oh I got the star
I got the stars don't cry don't cry
don't cry
hey Christ how do you brush do if you
enjoyed this video
considering hitting and subscribing
becoming a bro and click on the next
video for more see bros as always in the
next hahahaha alright turbo again [ __ ]
haha
[ __ ]